je n'ai pas bougé mais non mais changés
tous ces sujets de toute façon je bouge
pas beaucoup
zynga le permis charial et un jingle
permanent effectivement vous avez raison
garde bien alors gagné le mal et on se
concentre ses interviews croyances ok ok
est ce que vous croyez que la religion
juive est la meilleure non est ce que
vous croyez que le peuple juif et le
peuple élu c'est ce qui est écrit dans
les textes mais j'ai pas le droit de
vote donc je suis un peu dans là c'est
vrai vous avez pas le droit de vote puis
les imposer un droit de vote
ouais que deux passeports pour le moment
non je vous ai enfin je suis marocain
mais en tant que c'est dur pour les
français je suis canadien coincé je suis
arrivé j'ai demandé mes papiers je les
ai demandé en tant que canadiens je n'ai
pas demandé en tant que mannequin
voilà est-ce que vous croyez en dieu oui
est ce que vous croyez en vous oui oui
est ce que vous croyez au pouvoir
magique de goldorak
oui sinon je serais pas là ce soir ça
c'est clair
est ce que vous croyez que le psg peut
remonter oui oui parce que vous croyez
que l'om peut s'en sortir à bon à à
problèmes
allez pour le web il ya même des objets
2 pour l'om ce soir
pourquoi caroline vous êtes pour l'om
parce que je suis depuis longtemps
marseille et toute façon bien marseille
un peu plus l'accent est perdue de force
j'ai perdu ma aider à le perdre c'est
bien pire dieu est ce que vous croyez
que lionel jospin d'être présent la
république j'aimerais bien madelin
pressing mais je peux pas voter pour lui
encore une fois avec les terribles
j'aimerais lui dire tu as je t'aime bien
et alain madelin l'homme politique a pas
de cravate vous croyez qu'il est présent
dans le public
non je pense pas de justice donne du mal
on le sait
je pense pas du tout il ya déjà baissé
son froc à voir sinon on y voit des
vêtements etc les appareils qui va
rentrer à canal+
est ce que vous voyez qu'on peut faire
l'amour quatre fois de suite 4 soit une
dans la navy dans la vie dans la vraie
vie
ouais bien sûr ah ouais ouais bien sûr
mais elle a de la chance vous croyez à
l'amour toujours non moins quatre fois
de suite qu'ils croient plus voudra un
break après est ce que vous croyez qu'il
faut faire l'amour le samedi soir devant
tout le monde en parle sans bouger par
le jingle jusqu'idi sacha guitry l'une a
dit un truc lille a dit qu il ne fait
jamais la mort le samedi soir car s'il
pleut le dimanche je serai plus quoi
faire
c'est jacqueline et philippe du monde
qui m'ont envoyé cette blague faut bien
c'est mieux qu'une blague d'air et les
envoyer avec les bulls bien 25 ans ça me
disait un truc c'est que jacqueline et
fils et c'est par l'ue salue c'est des
gens qui va objets que je me sois
beaucoup du mail - ouais je sais jamais
si les gens qui vont venir la semaine
prochaine gad elmaleh il a un regard
formidables qui m'ont demandé votre
numéro de portable et tout écouter xive
agence matrimoniale ici enfin j'ai
appris ça je n'en sais d'ailleurs un
message pour evo 10 si quelqu'un cherche
une brune à forte poitrine de la
dernière fois que j'ai vu l'émission
elle est une fille sublime
oui aurélie dupont aurélie dupont à
danseuse incroyable est ce que vous
croyez que cette interview est terminée
non j'espère pas foot